économie environnement énergie au social
et
le développement durable à la réunion
c'est maintenant
bonjour je m'appelle david à et je vais
vous présenter une celle qui se déroule
hélas trop souvent au collège
voilà il faut faire une réunion des
chèques aux délégués c'est pas un skin a
fait peut-être à l'exploiter bah oui
allons-y
bonjour je m'appelle car là je suis éco
délégués du collège jean desse et je
vais vous présenter les rôles des éco
délégués montrer l'exemple aux autres
protéger l'environnement et surtout être
le porte parole de la classe
faire une union des éco délégués le
collège est sale ils vont faire passer
l'information aux élèves et dire
d'arrêter de jeter les papiers mais
comment faire l'information on pourrait
mettre des affiches visuel dans la dans
la courbe on peut relire la charte éco
école j'ai une meilleure idée on peut
rajouter des poubelles balaient toutes
ces causes est fini le collège salle
économiser jusqu'à 400 euros sur mes
consommation d'essence comment pour les
cours des distances je privilégie la
marche ou le vélo si j'ai plusieurs
kilomètres à parcourir j'utilise au
maximum le covoiturage ou les transports
en commun si je suis contraint
d'utiliser ma voiture
j'adopte une conduite souple et je roule
à allure modérée je réserve l'usagé de
la climatisation aux longs trajets
j'entretiens mon véhicule régulièrement
je coupe le moteur de mon véhicule quand
je suis à l'arrêt pendant plus d'une
minute alors vous voyez préserver
l'environnement c'est augmenter votre
pouvoir d'achat le conseil général agit
plus vive le pont durable et
économie environnement énergie au social
le développement durable à la réunion
c'est maintenant